we're not building bombers with it I
mean I think that's the useful this week
he's captured that much money and
neutralized it in a way and oh I think
of I just saw a man and a wire so I'm
thinking of a Philippe Petit yeah and
and I think oh that's a public work
that's a an event you know that was
purposeless but it sent people sent
their imaginations free for a moment and
now somehow there's something about it
having happened and now that powers are
gone too so it really is very ethereal
kind of floating image and it stays in
your mind I mean after elasians work is
down that'll stay in your mind so and in
many minds i happen to come up and i was
going to school when that happened I've
been working at night at Natural History
Museum and I came up at seven-thirty and
looked up and saw everybody was looking
up and go what what is this and you know
you see it and and and then everything
is gone now so the only the only remnant
is in your head you know
I think that's a purpose that's all it's
worth not so what so it costs a lot of
money are so that so many of these
things cost a lot of money in a way
that's a draw to the public I think the
public loves the idea that that it costs
so much money and has no purpose I think
that actually pulls them in the subways
project is probably my favorite I liked
it especially that it had a sort of a
slice of there's a class of people that
uses the subway and above ground it's a
different you know the upper class
highest class in the city won't go down
there you know so you're really talking
to a certain audience in that subway I
think that's my favorite I I put
something like five times more work than
they paid me for their I kept putting
more and more work in my wife finally
stopped me from putting our whole life
savings in I just got carried away you
know the situation itself was ideal for
me I think that's the